la ville de Kerson est désertée comme
vous pouvez le voir derrière moi il n'y
a quasiment personne seulement des
chiens qui aboient qui semble être
aujourd'hui les seuls habitants de la
ville des habitants il en reste tout de
même quelques quelques-uns puisque 15 %
de la population est encore présente ici
kirson est une ville meurtrie et c'est
vrai que c'est aussi une ville dont on a
beaucoup parlé parce que ça a été la
première prise entre guillemets de cette
capitale régionale pour les Russes qui
ont fini par se replier de l'autre côté
du Nièvre mais depuis leur retrait il
sème la terreur en bombardeant
régulièrement cette ville les nerfs sont
à bout pour beaucoup d'habitants
certains ont préféré fuir regardez
d'ailleurs ce reportage qu'on a réalisé
avec Catherine doristreet Mohamed Farhat
et demi troc ovale Chuck sur cette ville
qui souffre encore malgré le retrait des
Russes
lors de la bataille de Helson l'aéroport
a été le théâtre de combat
particulièrement féroce
la zone est toujours largement minée
non loin de là des tranches et où sont
positionnés des soldats Ukrainiens
c'est une guerre de position avec des
tranchées de l'artillerie et des drones
on est séparé de l'ennemi par le fleuve
niapre aux abords de l'antonievski
bridge sur les rives du Nièvre la balade
peut être mortelle l'armée russe est sur
l'autre rive et les snipers sont à
l'oeuvre les tirs d'artillerie se
répondent
de l'autre côté du fleuve un panache de
fumée s'élève sans doute une position
russe visée par l'armée ukrainienne
ce qui reste de la population de la
ville est prise entre deux feux dans le
centre de frèresson une file d'attentat
interminable pour espérer récupérer
quelques produits de première nécessité
à l'extérieur des habitants frigorifiés
se désespèrent alors que retentit une
énième frappe hier
je suis venu ici à 4h30 pour faire la
queue et je n'ai rien obtenu je pense
que je n'aurais rien non plus
aujourd'hui il y a des bombardements
sans arrêt
chaque jour
je ne peux plus le supporter
4 mois après le retrait de russe
la population est usée par des frappes
incessantes et souvent aveugle
en novembre 2022 sur cette place c'était
la joie et l'euphorie l'armée
ukrainienne n'était parvenue à chasser
les Russes de Helson aujourd'hui
l'atmosphère est bien différente dans la
ville une ville qui a perdu 85% de ses
habitants
fiché sur le niep le quartier de l'île
d'ostrive et sans doute celui qui
souffre le plus des bombardements
quotidiens il est sous contrôle
ukrainien mais les Russes ne sont qu'à
quelques centaines de mètres
derrière l'apparente banalité de l'image
d'une femme qui promène son chien le
danger est réel on reste c'est très
angoissant ça file au-dessus de nos
têtes on ne sait même pas d'où viennent
des tirs seuls les plus endurants
restent ici
ils ne veulent pas
peu d'appartements sont encore occupés
dans le quartier
les derniers habitants discutent au pied
de leur immeuble frappé de plein fouet à
deux reprises
il y a le risque de
se sédent alors elle est où et qui
pourrait m'emmener certains habitants
s'accrochent alors quartier coûte que
coûte d'autres ont fait le choix
douloureux de partir à la gare routière
un minibus s'apprête à quitter la ville
aujourd'hui le chauffeur est un peu
anxieux un éclat toucher l'arrière de
son véhicule
Olena et Natalia une mère et sa fille
habitante du quartier de stree par tel
aussi on a attendu le dernier moment en
espérant que quelque chose allait
changer mais on ne peut plus le
supporter plus longtemps
nous aimons notre ville nous aimons
notre maison et nous avons prévu de
revenir on ne part pas pour toujours
la reconquête de reverson restera une
victoire éclatante aux yeux des
Ukrainiens la fin de l'occupation russe
n'a certainement pas signifié la fin de
la guerre dans cette ville du front sud
ceux qui ont choisi de rester risquent
leur vie chaque jour